>> ♪ ♪
>> IT WAS A NIGHT OF FAR LEFT
IDEAS AND THAT DID NOT TOP WITH
THE TOPIC OF IMMIGRATION WITH
CANDIDATES ENDORSING OPEN
BORDERS.
>> I WOULD FOLLOW THAT UP IN MY
FIRST 100 DAYS WITH IMMIGRATION
REFORM THAT WILL HONOR ASYLUM
CLAIMS AND PUT UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS ON A PATHWAY TO
CITIZENSHIP.
MY PLAN INCLUDE GETTING RID OF
SECTION 1325.
>> WE WOULD NOT DETAIN ANY
FAMILIES FLEEING VIOLENCE AND WE
WOULD RE-WRITE OUR IMMIGRATION
LAWS.
FREE DREAMERS OF FEAR OF
DEPORTATION.
>> THE SEPARATION OF CHILDREN
FROM FAMILIES DOESN'T JUST GO ON
IN OUR BORDERS.
"ICE" IS RIPPING AWAY PARENTS
AND CHILDREN AND CREATING FEAR
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
>> ONE DEMOCRAT IS RETREATING.
THIS IS CASTRO.
>> I AM FOR DECRIMINALIZING, NOT
LEGALIZING.
PEOPLE ARE STILL PART OF A COURT
PROCESS AND STILL SUBJECT TO THE
LAWS OF THE UNITED STATES AND GO
THROUGH A PROCESS.
>> OPEN BORDERS IS A RIGHT WING
TALKING POINT.
WE HAVE 654 MILES OF FENCING AND
THOUSANDS OF BORDER PERSONNEL
AND PLANES AND HELICOPTERS AND
BOATS AND GUNS AND SECURITY
CAMERAS.
>> JESSE, WHAT DO YOU THINK OF
THAT?
>> BETO DOESN'T WANT A WALL.
TRUMP WANTS TO ISSUE DEPORTATION
AND THEY ISSUE INI HAVEATION --
INVITATION.
THEY WANTED TO PULL BACK BORDER
PATROL FROM THE FRONT LINE AND
DON'T WANT TO FUND THE BORDER
PATROL.
THEY ARE NOT DOING ANYTHING TO
STOP THE INFLUX.
WHEN THEY GET HERE THEY WANT TO
CATCH AND RELEASE.
THAT'S OPEN BORDERS.
ENOUGH SAID.
>> I THINK THE PROBLEM WITH THE
DEMOCRATS THEY HAVE GONE SO FAR
ON IMMIGRATION AND SO FAR ON
TAXES AND SPENDING AND RIPPING
PRIVATE HEALTHCARE AWAY.
IT'S THE MOST RADICAL
PROGRESSIVE CROP OF CANDIDATES
YOU HAVE EVER SEEN.
WHAT HAPPENED WITH PRESIDENT
OBAMA WITH CHANGE IN A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME HE WAS SHELLACKED
SO HARD SO THE DEMOCRATS WERE
OUT OF POWER.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE CAN'T HANDLE
ALL OF THAT RADICAL CHANGE THAT
QUICKLY.
THIS CROP OF DEMOCRATS IS DOING
IT TWICE AS FAST AND TWICE AS
CRAZY.
IT'S GOING TO HURT THEM.
>> WAIT A SECOND, JESSE.
JUST THIS VERY DAY
UNEMPLOYMENTNY NANCY PELOSI
SAYING CHILDREN COME FIRST.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THERE IS
NOT ABUSE OF CHILDREN.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE GUY THAT SAID
WE HAVE AN INVASION AND WE NEED
TO BUILD A WALL?
DEMOCRATS MAY SAY YOU ARE NOT
SINCERE ABOUT HELPING ANYBODY.
>> SO THERE IS A CRISIS NOW?
>> IT'S A HUMANITARIAN ISSUE.
>> IT'S NOT A TERRORIST ATTACK.
>> YESTERDAY WHEN YOU LISTENED
TO CASTRO, HE IS RIGHT.
THIS IS A REPUBLICAN TALKING
POINT.
NOBODY IS CALLING FOR OPEN
BORDERS, BUT YOU HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH THE ZERO TOLERANCE PROBLEM.
REMAIN IN MEXICO POLICY IS NOT
IN KEEPING WITH U.S. VALUES AND
NOT MAKING THEIR JOBS EASIER OR
MORE EFFICIENT.
>> CLOSE THE ASYLUM LOOP HOLE
AND TREAT THE CENTRAL-AMERICAN
MIGRANTS THE SAME WAY AS THE
MEXICANS.
>> OH BAY THE LAW.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> I AGREE.
OBEY THE LAW AND ENFORCE IT.
>> BETO O'ROURKE SAID WE WOULD
NOT DETAIN ANYONE FLEEING
VIOLENCE.
THAT'S ALL OF THEM.
>> YES.
THEY HAVE NO PROCESS.
THEY HAVE NO SYSTEM.
THEY HAVE WISHES, BUT THEY CAN'T
EXPLAIN WHAT TO DO.
-- WE KNOW WHO CAUSED THE
CHILDREN'S CRISIS.
ACTVISITS EGGED ON THE CAR VANS
AND THAT CAUSED US TO REACT.
IF CONGRESS LISTENED TO TRUMP, A
CHILD WILL BE ALIVE THAT DIED.
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT PREVENTING
THIS FROM HAPPENING.
WHEN YOU HAVE THOUSANDS AND
THOUSAND OF PEOPLE COMING, A
LARGE MOVEMENT OF PEOPLE COMING,
THERE ARE RISKS PEOPLE WILL GET
HURT AND WILL DIE.
IT HAPPENS.
IT'S TERRIBLE.
IT WOULD NOT HAVE HAPPENED IF
YOU HAD ACTUALLY ADDRESSED THE
PROBLEM WHEN ALL OF US WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE PROBLEM.
THE POINT IS THESE POLITICIANS
ARE TOO SCARED TO ADDRESS THIS
PROBLEM BECAUSE OF THE ACTIVISTS
CONSENSUS MEDIA.
TRUMP WILL NAIL THIS IN A
DEBATE:
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DECIDE OUR
IMMIGRATION POLICY?
OTHER COUNTRIES OR US?
THAT'S THE SIMPLE QUESTION.
DEMOCRATS CAN'T DECIDE ON THAT
QUESTION THE SAME WAY THEY CAN'T
DECIDE ON HOMELESSNESS OR LAW
AND ORDER.
IT'S NOT THE VICTIM.
IT'S ALWAYS THE CRIMINAL.
IT'S NOT THE STORE OWNER, IT'S
THE GUY LOITERING IN FRONT OF
THE STORE.
IT'S NOT THE CITIZEN IT'S THE
OTHER COUNTRY.
THE DEMOCRATS NEVER PICK THE
RIGHT SIDE AND NEVER HAVE A
PROCESS.
>> WE PICKED THE RIGHT SIDE
BECAUSE AMERICA IS A COUNTRY OF
IMMIGRANTS.
AFTER WORLD WAR II WHEN WE
REALIZED WE KEPT OUT JEWISH
PEOPLE FLEEING THE GERMANS, WE
WILL CHANGE --
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> WHILE WE HAVE BEEN ON AIR, A
SENATE BILL PASSED FOR THE
EMERGENCY MONEY THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION ASKED FOR, FOR A
FEW MONTHS.
THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO GO TO
RECESS AND THEY WANTED THIS
DEALT WITH.
THE TIDE WAS TURNING ON THE
NARRATIVE.
THE STORYLINE WAS GOING TO
FOLLOW THEM THAT THEY WERE
BLOCKING RESOURCES TO HELP TAKE
CARE OF THESE KIDS.
>> BETTER LATE THAN NEVER.
SHOULD HAVE HAPPENED MONTHS AGO.
I WANT THE DEMOCRATS TO STEP UP
AND TALK ABOUT WHY ALL OF THESE
PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO POUR INTO
THE UNITED STATES.
IT'S BECAUSE THE ECONOMY IS
STRONG.
YOU HAVE JOB OPENINGS, A RECORD
NUMBER.
1.62-MILLION MORE JOBS ARE
AVAILABLE HERE.
THE STRANGE THING ABOUT THESE
DEMOCRATIC POLICIES IS IT WILL
DRIVE THE ECONOMY INTO THE
RECESSION IF ONE GOT ELECTED AND
THAT WOULD SLOW IMMIGRATION.
>> AND THE CORRUPT
CENTRAL-AMERICAN COUNTRIES DON'T
SPEND ANY MONEY ON HOUSING AND
WELFARE.
THEY PUSH ALL OF THE POOR PEOPLE
NORTH.
>> AND DECRIMINALIZING IS THE
SAME THING AS LEGALIZING.
OPEN BORDERS.
>> I DON'T THINK MEXICANS ARE
COMING ACROSS THE BORDERS IN
INCREASING NUMBERS.
IT'S CENTRAL-AMERICANS.
THEY ARE FLEEING BECAUSE OF THE